so it's been a big week for hot takes
over russia's non-invasion of ukraine
but should you trust any of them that's
the question well i'm going to take you
through just a couple of tweets to give
you an idea of the level of social media
analysis out there and i'll let you
decide these were written by melinda
herring who's from the atlantic council
which is a major washington funded think
tank remember a think tank is an
organization which is given a conclusion
and then is tasked with coming up with
the proof for it so on friday the 11th
of february herring scares the hell out
of ukraine by tweeting
putin has big weekend plans in ukraine
one he's gonna cut power and heat knock
out ukrainian navy and air force kill
general staff and hit them with cyber
attack two then install pro-russian
president and three
then resort to full-scale military
invasion if ukraine doesn't give in i
mean how specific is that and i have to
say it's worth bearing in mind at this
point that this woman's twitter bio
literally uses the words trying to nudge
history in the right direction then cut
to february 14th where after a quiet
weekend melissa decides to hedge her
bets and issues somewhat of a climb down
by responding to her first objectively
inflammatory tweet she writes emotions
running high and i let them get the
better of me i still expect action this
week but putin may drag this out we
still don't know bottom line is that i
recognize that i need to be more
judicious
and then the end of this little story
where justifiably someone asks if
melissa a fully paid up informed think
tanker will stop posting her juicy
predictions if they don't come true her
response
no
she says no way i'm a think tank expert
we make predictions we get some right we
get some wrong things looked mighty bad
on friday they still do putin may strike
on wednesday or he may sit on the border
and just menace us all
vvp hasn't called yet to tell me his
plans did he call you
worth
bearing all that
in mind